[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 14 juin
avec une l'entre-deux tours des
élections législatives les candidats
accélèrent leur campagne quelques jours
du second tour et notamment les
candidats aient l'air ils sont en danger
dans les yvelines
de nombreux bastions que l'on pensait
intouchable pourrait basculer dimanche
c'est le cas de la deuxième
circonscription
c'est un événement qui s'est inscrit
dans le paysage culturel parisien le
festival solidays 19e édition est
organisée du 23 au 25 juin
comme chaque année de nombreuses
personnalités soutiennent l'événement
pour récolter des fonds et lutter contre
le sida et en fin de journal retour sur
l'événement qui marque le début de l'été
à saint cyr l'école la fête de la ville
cette année le thème portait sur la
magie et le fantastique de copuler les
apprentis sorciers
c'est une disparition qualifiée
d'inquiétante la police nationale lance
un appel à témoins pour retrouver
mélissa bono une adolescente de 14 ans
qui a fugué de chez elles de bois d'arcy
le 26 mai dernier selon les informations
communiquées par la police
la jeune fille est décrite avec de longs
cheveux bruns de type européen de
corpulence normale elle pourrait être
également vêtue d'un legging et d'une
veste sans manche
si vous avez des informations à propos
de cette disparition
contacter le commissariat de police de
plaisir au 01 30 07 71 30
dans le reste de l'actualité de la
politique forcément à quatre jours du
second tour des élections législatives
la droite est en danger dans les
yvelines et notamment dans la 2e
circonscription celle du député maire de
vélizy pascal thévenot le candidat de la
république en marche jean noël barrot
est arrivé là
je mens en tête du premier tour les deux
finalistes s'activent sur le terrain
pour tenter de convaincre notamment les
abstentionnistes reportage de camille
lambert et mélanie poquet il est dans la
position de l'outsider le 11 juin pascal
thévenot arrive deuxième dans la
circonscription
le candidat à l'est républicain cible
surtout les abstentionnistes plus de 41%
des électeurs n'ont pas voté
là c'est d'aller sur le terrain mais
encore de manière encore plus présente
pour aller chercher tous les électeurs
qui sont pas allés voter
puis leur faire comprendre que ceux qui
sont allés voter qui ont été tentées par
l'image du président de la république
que qu'un député c'est pas simplement un
illustrateur c'est quelqu'un qui est
très présente sur son terrain qui a
attendu aussi partie des électeurs qui
en soutien avec tous les élus locaux
et si tous les projets avancent vite
surveillée dans la circonscription c'est
parce que je suis sur le terrain
si le député sortant espère retrouver la
dynamique qui l'a envoyé à l'assemblée
nationale en 2016
plus de 20 points le séparent de son
rival jean noël barrot le candidat de la
république en marche obtient plus de 43%
lui aussi continue sa campagne
rien n'est joué encore une fois de
nombreux et électrices et électeurs ne
sont pas déplacés il faut aller à leur
rencontre les convaincre c'est important
de voter de s'exprimer lors de ces
élections législatives l'accueil est
favorable mais il ya une forte attente
qui s'adressent à nous qui s'adresse à
emmanuel macron pour apporter des
réponses concrètes aux problèmes des
français ils sont nombreux je crois que
l'attenté très forte et qu'il faudra que
les élus soient à la hauteur de cette
attente le 18 juin la deuxième
circonscription des yvelines pourrait
basculer
elle est détenue par la droite depuis
1988 et l'élection d'un élu rpr
c'est une étape obligatoire pour tous
les jeunes français depuis la fin du
service militaire il ya vingt ans la
journée de défense et citoyenneté est
l'occasion pour eux de s'informer sur
leurs devoirs et leurs droits et
renforcer aussi le lien avec l'armée la
jdc comme on l'appelle également doit
être réalisée entre 16 et 25 ans le
cirfa de versailles a ouvert ses portes
pour une session reportage de stéphane
servant et charline hurel ils sont plus
de 580 1000 cette année à passer une
journée dans un centre du service
national
c'est la dernière étape obligatoire pour
tous ces jeunes de 17 à 25 ans au
programme présentation des métiers de la
défense du recrutement mais aussi
sensibilisation à la sécurité routière
une journée de dialogue avec des
animateurs sur des sujets d'actualité et
les menaces qui pèsent sur la france
depuis les récents attentats les jeunes
se sentent très concernés par le travail
des armées qu'en voile et les
patrouilles dans la gare on voit les
militaires des filets et aujourd'hui on
se dit vraiment c'est quelque chose
d'important qui font au cours de la
journée ils échangent avec des
militaires sur leur métier leur parcours
leur vie mais le centre qui voit passer
près de 150 jeunes par jour a aussi pour
mission de détecter les jeunes en
difficulté de lecture ou en échec
scolaire pour l'armée c'est un enjeu de
cohésion sociale sensibiliser tous les
jeunes à l'importance de la défense a
expliqué ses missions et ses moyens et
pourquoi pas établir des contacts en vue
d'un recrutement et nous explique qu'il
ya beaucoup de métier dans l'armée que
c'est pas parce que par exemple je suis
en commerce que je pourrais pas faire
mécanicien ou que je pourrais pas faire
infirmière ou quelque chose comme ça il
y en a énormément j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses l'armée de terre l'armée de
l'air et la marine recrute
en effet chaque année 21 mille jeunes
pour des postes très variés des jeunes
sans diplôme
jusqu'à des bac + 5 ondes et sur la
recherche de valeurs prônées sur la
recherche structure
on est sur la recherche de solidarité et
puis oui bien entendu il reste dieu soit
loué en cours le moule aventures de
pouvoir partir à l'étranger
certains aussi viennent chez nous avec
l'espoir d'avoir l'espoir justifier
d'avoir une formation qualifiante
ce qui est vraiment le cas en fin de
journée pour tous ces jeunes avec un
questionnaire et la remise de leur
certificat individuel de participation
sésame qui fait d'eux désormais un
citoyen ou une citoyenne la 19e édition
du festival solidays est organisé du 23
au 25 juin comme chaque année plus de 80
concerts sont prévus sur l'hippodrome de
longchamp à paris
objectif récolter des fonds pour lutter
contre le sida l'événement a déjà
rassemblé plus de 2,5 millions de
personnes depuis sa création et sera une
nouvelle fois soutenu par la région ile
de france mickaël et demi d'euros le
combat continue une nouvelle fois en
musique pour le solidays le festival est
reconduit du 23 au 25 juin pour une 19e
édition sur l'hippodrome de longchamp à
paris
objectif récolter des fonds pour lutter
contre le sida
cette année 80 concerts sont programmés
sur cette scène j'ai le sentiment que
pour cette dixième édition solidays à
une programmation toujours aussi riche
et varié elle se veut éclectique ce
qu'on est là pour voir donner envie à
tout le monde se veut multi
générationnel parce qu on est là pour
les jeunes et les moins jeunes
l'ambiance solidaire c'est une ambiance
rock hip hop familiale chanson française
décalée kitsch c'est de l'information
c'est comment on appelle ça de l'émotion
le festival jongleurs encore cette année
entre les artistes inconnus du grand
public et les têtes d'affiché parmi les
nouveautés les festivaliers pourront
voir en action le groupe de rock
malgache dit brence parmi les chanteurs
confirmés l'artiste fait participera ce
rendez vous tout le monde veut faire
solide et en général c'est un roman un
festival espace est l'unique autant pour
la cause qui est allé kristijan c'est
très agréable parce que public est hyper
chaleureux
au programme également des expositions
des tables auront l'ailé conférence sur
le sida la sexualité des thèmes
importants pour la région ile-de-france
qui n'hésitent pas à verser huit cent
mille euros dans le festival environ 4
euros par festival délit parce que le
sila n'a pas disparu parce que 40 % des
séropositifs de france sont en ile de
france parce que l'île de france est
aussi le lieu de la fête
et je crois que c'est important qu'on
continue à véhiculer ses messages de
prévention vis-à-vis de tous les jeunes
et ça c'est le rôle de son désir c'est
pour ça que la région est aussi
mobilisée après une fréquentation record
plus de 200 mille festivaliers en 2016
l'événement la fiche toujours pas
complet pourrait voir une baisse cette
année selon les organisateurs nouvelle
qui n'enlève pas l' enthousiasme des
artistes tout j'aurais cracher nom est
la fin du suspense approche le seuil
haut donnera sa décision le 13 septembre
prochain à lima au pérou et on saura
enfin qui organisera les jo 2000 24
heures pour faire pencher la balance du
côté de la candidature parisienne
quelques coups de pédales ou été donné
ce matin au vélodrome nationale vous le
voyez parmi les personnalités présentes
on pouvait apercevoir le staff et les
cyclistes de l'équipe de france ou
encore le président de saint quentin en
yvelines michel logis
on veut les jeux dans ce vélodrome donc
la meilleure des choses c'est de prouver
par la participation que des choses
peuvent se faire voilà donc même moi qui
ne suis pas cyclistes j'ai souhaité être
aussi sur un vélo pour faire voir notre
détermination pour avoir les jeux à 50
heures de jeu ce week-end le parc du
château de plaisir était en fait la
ville organisait son traditionnel
festival les escales d'ailleurs un
voyage autour du monde à la découverte
des différentes cultures en musique et
en gastronomie retour sur cette journée
avec nicolas landry et camille lambert
les spectateurs se sont laissés emporter
par les rythmes latinos du conservatoire
de plaisir lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs une dizaine de groupes a fait
voyager l'auditoire toute la journée de
la chorale au swing en passant par du
rock ou les musiques du monde
aujourd'hui on a présenté un répertoire
latine et aux caraïbes faisant un clin
d'oeil à la guadeloupe à la martinique
à cuba est ainsi qu'au brésil plages et
des villageois de l'eau ventiler devant
les illois aujourd'hui j'ai voyagé quoi
un répertoire exotique à l'image de la
diversité culturelle de la ville plus de
40 ethnies différentes cohabitent
ensemble à plaisir c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui a motivé la création de ce festival
des arts du monde il ya déjà quinze ans
c'est de réunir tout le monde puisqu'on
a la chance d'avoir ce parc magnifique
qui nous permet de réunir plus de dix
mille personnes sur une journée
véritablement plaisir est tournée vers
la culture vers les spectacles et var le
rassemblement humain c'est ce qui
m'importe le plus c'est que plaisir soit
la dimension de fait la dimension
humaine et qui dit fête dit bien sûr
jeux et animations par endroit les
visiteurs se sont envolées grâce à une
grande roue écologique ou se prenaient
pour des pirates
on vient tous les ans et c'est vrai
qu'après deux mondes il ya beaucoup de
jeux pour les enfants c'est super active
c'est à l'intérieur donc c'est tout les
maintenant pas de plaisir tout ça perd
beaucoup d'activités s'applique beaucoup
c'est bien là ce genre de rendez vous
pour la saison estivale le parc du
château de plaisir n'a pas fini
d'accueillir les curieux des pièces de
théâtre seront notamment joué du 30 juin
au 2 juillet
et la fête également du côté de saint
cyr l'école les apprentis sorciers avait
eu rendez vous pour la traditionnelle
fête de la ville la thématique cette
année magique et fantastique
nicolas d'andry notre journaliste est
passé au travers des sorts pour vous
présenter ce reportage avec camille
lambert
[Musique]
il était farceur les sorciers à
saint-cyr-l'ecole nombre d'entre eux se
sont retrouvés pour une après midi
festive
les apprentis magiciens ont même pu
profiter de leurs conseils pour réaliser
leur baguette magique
attention on ne rigole pas avec les
baguettes ou droit des coûts de la
braguette spéciale de magnifiques pour
transformer les gens sont encore légion
est ce que j'aime bien et quand nous
étions allés manger
j'ai fait une base et la quête monique
qui a beaucoup et c'est magique dans ces
magiciens oui des démonstrations et des
ateliers d'alchimie pour créer ses
propres potion une véritable école de
sorciers à ciel ouvert et c'est sous
l'oeil bienveillant de gandalf leblanc
que les moldus en ont profité mon ami
vous avez vu que notre magie a opéré
puisque nous avions commandé le soleil
et qu'il est au rendez vous j'ai aussi
autour de moi beaucoup de gens qui se
sont mis à l'oeuvre pour réussir cette
fête une plongée au coeur de la
sorcellerie le temps d'une journée
et si la fête est terminée à
saint-cyr-l'ecole les pouvoirs magiques
eux resteront attention à ne pas vous
faire transformer en corniche on a c'est
la fin de ce 7 8 le journal avant de
vous quitter nous souhaitions vous dire
bonne chance à tous les bacheliers 2017
les épreuves du bac débute demain matin
avec la traditionnelle épreuve de
philosophie
bonne chance surtout si vous êtes encore
en pleines révisions quant aux autres
rendez vous demain pour une nouvelle
édition bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]